qué significa la distancia en física la
distancia es la longitud total de la
ruta recorrida es decir si un objeto
viajo adelante atrás y adelante para
encontrar la distancia total recorrida
tomamos esta longitud de ruta positiva
la sumamos con esta longitud de la ruta
y luego la sumamos con esta otra
longitud de la ruta y así encontramos la
distancia total recorrida y es por eso
que la fórmula de la distancia total
recorrida la podemos ver como la suma de
cada una de las longitudes recorridas en
cada ruta individual la unidad de la
distancia es en metros y no es un vector
siempre será positiva o cero y nunca
puede ser negativa como ilusión problema
en donde se involucra la distancia total
recorrida digamos que tenemos esta
gráfica y la pregunta es cuál es la
distancia recorrida por el objeto de 0 a
6 segundos de 0 a 2 segundos el objeto
se movió hacia adelante 4 metros
a cuatro segundos el objeto se movió
hacia atrás cuatro metros y de cuatro a
seis segundos el objeto se movió de
nuevo hacia atrás otros cuatro metros y
cuatro metros más cuatro metros más
cuatro metros nos da 12 metros que es la
distancia recorrida que significa el
desplazamiento en física de
desplazamiento es la diferencia entre la
posición inicial y la posición final así
que si un objeto fue hacia adelante
hacia atrás y nuevamente hacia adelante
el desplazamiento puede representarse
como una flecha que va desde la posición
inicial hasta la posición final y es por
eso que la fórmula para el
desplazamiento se representa como la
distancia final menos la distancia
inicial está delta representa el cambio
en en este caso el valor final menos el
valor inicial las unidades del
desplazamiento son metros y el
desplazamiento es un vector lo que
significa que si el desplazamiento va
hacia la izquierda o hacia abajo
tendremos un desplazamiento negativo en
otras palabras si
terminamos más a la izquierda de donde
estamos significa que nuestro
desplazamiento fue negativo y si
terminamos más abajo de donde estábamos
nuestro desplazamiento vertical será
negativo como luce un ejemplo de un
problema que involucra al desplazamiento
si tenemos esta gráfica y nos preguntan
cuál es el desplazamiento del objeto de
0 a 6 segundos pues no nos va a
interesar si el objeto fue hacia
adelante o hacia atrás o si cambió de
dirección sólo nos va a interesar en
donde comenzó y en donde terminó la
posición inicial fue de 0 y la posición
final a los 6 segundos fue de menos 4
metros por lo que el desplazamiento fue
de menos 4 metros ya que terminamos 4
metros por atrás de donde comenzamos que
significa la rapidez la rapidez es una
forma de medir qué tanto se está
moviendo un objeto la rapidez es un
escalar que para nuestros propósitos es
una forma de decir que no es un vector
la rapidez se define como la tasa de la
distancia por el tiempo podemos definir
la rapidez promedio como la tasa de la
distancia por él
durante un intervalo grande de tiempo o
podemos definir la rapidez instantánea
como la tasa de la distancia por el
tiempo en un instante particular del
tiempo en otras palabras si un objeto
está siguiendo una ruta muy grande
podremos encontrar la rapidez promedio
de todo el recorrido dividiendo la
distancia total de todo el recorrido
entre el tiempo que le llevó recorrer
toda esta distancia o para determinar la
rapidez instantánea podemos ver una
distancia infinitesimalmente pequeña y
ver el tiempo que le llevó recorrer esta
distancia infinitesimal las unidades de
la rapidez son metros por segundo y no
es un vector de manera que el valor de
la rapidez puede ser positivo o cero
pero nunca negativo como luce un ejemplo
de un problema que involucra a la
rapidez si tenemos esta gráfica y
queremos determinar la rapidez promedio
del objeto de 0 a 6 segundos debemos
recordar que la rapidez promedio es la
distancia entre el tiempo
distancia de 0 a 6 segundos es de 4
metros más 4 metros más otros 4 metros
lo que nos da una distancia de 12 metros
y el tiempo que nos llevó recorrer esta
distancia de 12 metros pues fue de 6
segundos lo que nos da una rapidez
promedio de 2 metros por segundo que
significa la velocidad la velocidad es
otra manera de determinar qué tanto se
está moviendo un objeto pero este es un
vector lo que significa que la velocidad
puede ser positiva o negativa la
velocidad se define como el
desplazamiento con respecto al tiempo
podemos definir la velocidad promedio
como la tasa del desplazamiento por el
tiempo durante un intervalo grande de
tiempo y también podemos definir la
velocidad instantánea como la tasa del
desplazamiento por el tiempo en un
instante particular del tiempo en otras
palabras si un objeto recorre una ruta
larga y queremos determinar la velocidad
promedio de este objeto durante todo el
recorrido tomar
el desplazamiento de todo el recorrido y
lo dividiremos entre el tiempo que le
llevó a hacer este recorrido o si
queremos la velocidad instantánea en un
momento particular del tiempo vamos a
tomar un desplazamiento infinitesimal en
ese momento del tiempo y lo dividiremos
entre el tiempo que le llevó realizar
ese desplazamiento las unidades de la
velocidad son metros por segundo y si es
un vector así que esto puede ser
negativo por lo que las velocidades que
van hacia la izquierda o hacia abajo se
consideran como velocidades negativas
como luces un ejemplo de un problema que
involucre a la velocidad si tenemos esta
gráfica y queremos determinar cuál es la
velocidad promedio del objeto de 0 a 6
segundos tenemos que recordar que la
velocidad promedio es el desplazamiento
entre el tiempo y ya que el objeto
comienza en cero metros y a los seis
segundos termina a menos cuatro metros
desplazamiento aquí es de -4 metros y el
tiempo que le llevó a realizar este
desplazamiento fue de 6 segundos lo que
nos da una velocidad promedio de menos
dos tercios metros por segundo para el
intervalo de tiempo entre 0 y 6
qué significa la aceleración la
aceleración es la tasa a la que la
velocidad cambia con el tiempo podemos
cambiar la velocidad aumentando la o
disminuyendo la o incluso cambiando de
dirección y es bueno recordar que la
aceleración apunta en la dirección de la
fuerza neta del objeto en otras palabras
si tenemos una pelota que tiene una
velocidad inicial 20 que va hacia la
derecha y la pelota aumenta su velocidad
a una velocidad final hacia la derecha
tuvo que haber una aceleración ya que la
velocidad cambio y ya que la aceleración
siempre apunta en la misma dirección que
el cambio en la velocidad como este
objeto ganó velocidad hacia la derecha
la aceleración apunta hacia la derecha
lo que significa que también hubo una
fuerza neta en esta pelota hacia la
derecha también la fórmula para la
aceleración es el cambio en la velocidad
entre el tiempo que le llevó a realizar
este cambio en la velocidad y ya que de
alta significa valor final menos valor
inicial podemos escribir esto como la
velocidad final menos la velocidad
inicial
entre el tiempo que le llevó a esta
velocidad cambiar las unidades de la
aceleración son metros por segundo al
cuadrado ya que la aceleración nos dice
cuántos metros por segundo está
cambiando la velocidad cada segundo y la
aceleración es un vector lo que
significa que puede ser negativo si la
aceleración va hacia la izquierda o
hacia abajo típicamente consideramos a
estas aceleraciones con un valor
negativo como luce un problema que
involucra a la aceleración vamos a
determinar en cuales dos casos la
aceleración de la bola va hacia la
derecha si la bola se mueve hacia la
derecha y se va deteniendo debe haber
una fuerza neta hacia la izquierda que
la está deteniendo y si la fuerza neta
apunta hacia la izquierda la aceleración
también apunta hacia la izquierda ya que
la aceleración y la fuerza neta siempre
apuntan en la misma dirección si la bola
se mueve a la derecha y está aumentando
su velocidad debe haber una fuerza neta
que está apuntando hacia la derecha que
le está aumentando la velocidad
tanto también debe haber una aceleración
que va hacia la derecha si la bola se
mueve hacia la izquierda y va más
despacio entonces debe haber una fuerza
neta que va hacia la derecha que está
haciendo que vaya más despacio lo que
significa que la aceleración también
está apuntando hacia la derecha y si la
bola se mueve hacia la izquierda y va
más rápido tiene que haber una fuerza
neta que va hacia la izquierda que está
haciendo que la bola vaya más rápido por
lo tanto la aceleración también va a
apuntar hacia la derecha y ya que la
aceleración siempre apunta en la misma
dirección que la fuerza neta podemos ver
que las opciones b y c son los dos casos
en los que la aceleración apunta hacia
la derecha como interpretamos una
gráfica de posición contra tiempo el
valor de la gráfica de la posición de x
en otras palabras en cierto tiempo t si
medimos el valor de la gráfica en el eje
vertical este valor nos va a dar la
posición en ese tiempo t porque nos
interesan las gráficas de posición
contra tiempo una razón es que la
pendiente nos va a dar la velocidad del
objeto así que si podemos determinar la
pendiente podremos encontrar la
velocidad como encontramos la pendiente
encontramos la región en la que queremos
determinar la pendiente y vamos a tomar
el desplazamiento vertical y lo vamos a
dividir entre el desplazamiento
horizontal que es el cambio en x entre
el cambio en t en esta porción de la
gráfica y ya que aquí el desplazamiento
vertical entre el desplazamiento
horizontal es igual al cambio de la
posición entre el tiempo la pendiente
será igual a la velocidad también
podemos saber si existe una aceleración
en el objeto en una gráfica de posición
contra el tiempo si ésta tiene o no una
curvatura una curvatura que luce como
una sonrisa sin
a una aceleración positiva y una
curvatura que luce como una boca triste
significa que hay una aceleración
negativa las gráficas que tienen una
pendiente constante tendrán una
velocidad constante y cero aceleración
como luce a un problema que involucra a
una gráfica de posición contra tiempo
digamos que tenemos esta gráfica y
queremos conocer cuál es la velocidad
instantánea del movimiento a los 7
segundos
encontramos nuestros 7 segundos y para
encontrar la velocidad en esta región
tenemos que encontrar la pendiente en
esta región y como aquí la pendiente es
constante podemos encontrar la pendiente
usando cualquier par de puntos en esta
región y elegimos 6 segundos y 8
segundos porque es más conveniente así
que esto es el desplazamiento vertical
entre el desplazamiento horizontal que
es igual el desplazamiento vertical en
este caso es el cambio en la posición y
el desplazamiento horizontal es el
cambio en el tiempo y ya que entre 6
segundos y 8 segundos
la gráfica tiene una caída de 4 metros
el desplazamiento será de menos 4 metros
y el tiempo que le llevó a esto fue de 2
segundos es decir el desplazamiento
horizontal por lo que la pendiente en
esta región es igual a menos 2 metros
por segundo y esto es igual a la
velocidad en esta región
como interpretamos una gráfica de
velocidad contra tiempo lo primero que
debemos saber es que el valor de la
gráfica de la velocidad ve el valor en
el eje vertical nos da el valor de la
velocidad en ese instante particular del
tiempo porque nos interesan estas
gráficas de velocidad contra tiempo una
razón es que el valor de la pendiente en
cualquier momento nos va a dar la
aceleración del objeto en ese momento
del tiempo encontramos la pendiente
usando la definición que es el
desplazamiento vertical entre el
desplazamiento horizontal y en este caso
el desplazamiento vertical es el cambio
en b y el desplazamiento horizontal es
el cambio en el tiempo y ya que el
cambio de la velocidad entre el tiempo
es la definición de la aceleración pues
la pendiente en una gráfica de velocidad
contra tiempo nos da la aceleración
también el área bajo cualquier sección
particular de esta curva entre dos
valores del tiempo nos va a dar el
desplazamiento del objeto entre esos dos
momentos del tiempo como luce un
problema que involucre a las gráficas de
velocidad contra tiempo digamos que
tenemos esta gráfica y queremos conocer
cuál es la aceleración del objeto a los
dos segundos ya que la aceleración va a
ser igual a la pendiente a los dos
segundos
necesitamos encontrar la pendiente en
esta región y ya que la pendiente es
constante podemos encontrar la pendiente
entre cualquier par de puntos aquí yo
voy a elegir cero y cuatro segundos
porque me es más conveniente y vamos a
calcular la pendiente que siempre es el
desplazamiento vertical entre el
desplazamiento horizontal en este caso
el desplazamiento vertical es el cambio
en la velocidad y el desplazamiento
horizontal es el cambio en el tiempo el
cambio en la velocidad entre cero
segundos y cuatro segundos es de menos
60 metros por segundo y el cambio en el
tiempo entre 0 y 4 segundos es de 4
segundos lo que nos da una pendiente de
menos 15 metros por segundo al cuadrado
que también es la aceleración en este
periodo de tiempo y si queremos conocer
cuál es el desplazamiento de 4 a 6
segundos podemos determinar el área bajo
la curva en esta región de 4 a 6
segundos
de un rectángulo es base por altura y en
este caso la base de este rectángulo es
de 2 segundos y la altura es de menos 30
metros por segundo lo que nos da una
área de menos 60 metros lo que significa
que el desplazamiento de 4 a 6 segundos
fue de menos 60 metros como podemos
interpretar una gráfica de aceleración
contra tiempo pues el valor en el eje
vertical nos va a dar la aceleración en
esta gráfica así que si vemos el valor
de esta gráfica en un momento particular
del tiempo el valor en el eje vertical
nos va a dar la aceleración del objeto
en ese momento del tiempo en este caso
el valor de la pendiente nos va a dar el
tirón lo que realmente no es muy usado
pero lo que sí necesitan saber es que el
área bajo la curva en esta gráfica nos
va a dar el cambio en la velocidad así
que si pueden encontrar el área bajo la
curva entre dos momentos del tiempo en
estas gráficas de aceleración contra
tiempo esta área va a ser igual al
cambio en la velocidad del objeto entre
esos dos momentos del tiempo y como luce
a un problema que involucra a una gracia
de aceleración contratiempo digamos que
un objeto inicia en reposo entre igual a
cero y queremos saber cuál es su
velocidad a los seis segundos tenemos
que usar esta gráfica de aceleración
contra tiempo para responder a la
pregunta recordemos que el área va a ser
igual al cambio de la velocidad del
objeto entre dos momentos del tiempo y
ya que nos interesa el tiempo de 0 a 6
segundos quiero encontrar el área abajo
en la curva entre 0 y 6 segundos
esta primera área va a ser un área
positiva la segunda área va a ser un
área negativa y la tercera área va a ser
también un área negativa pero vean que
esta primera área triangular va a
cancelar la segunda área triangular ya
que una es positiva y la otra es igual
pero negativa así que en este caso la
única área que nos interesa es esta de
acá este rectángulo cuya altura es de
menos 10 metros por segundo al cuadrado
y cuya base es de 2 segundos lo que nos
da un área de menos 20 metros por
segundo que también va a hacer el cambio
en la velocidad del objeto
y ya que este objeto comenzó en reposo
entre igual a cero si cambio su
velocidad en menos 20 metros por segundo
la velocidad final a los 6 segundos va a
ser de menos 20 metros por segundo qué
significan las fórmulas cinemáticas las
fórmulas cinemáticas son las fórmulas
que relacionan las cinco variables
cinemáticas que es el desplazamiento la
velocidad inicial la velocidad final la
aceleración y el tiempo pero estas
fórmulas sólo se cumplen si la
aceleración es constante normalmente
estas tres fórmulas no las dan en el
examen pero no nos dan la última fórmula
para acordarnos de esta fórmula el lado
izquierdo es la velocidad final más la
velocidad inicial entre 2 es decir el
promedio de las velocidades y el lado
derecho es el desplazamiento entre el
tiempo que es la definición de velocidad
promedio así que el promedio de las
velocidades va a ser igual a la
velocidad promedio si un objeto está en
movimiento y este objeto le lleva cierto
tiempo te cambia
su velocidad de velocidad inicial a
velocidad final y durante este tiempo el
objeto tiene cierta aceleración y cierto
desplazamiento todos estos elementos
estarán relacionados por estas fórmulas
si es que la aceleración es constante
como luce un ejemplo de un problema que
involucra a las fórmulas cinemáticas
digamos que una ardilla confundida
comienza en reposo y aumenta su rapidez
con una aceleración constante durante
tres segundos mientras recorre nueve
metros podemos encontrar la aceleración
de la ardilla usando la segunda fórmula
cinemática el desplazamiento es de nueve
metros la velocidad inicial es cero ya
que comienza en reposo la aceleración es
nuestra incógnita y el tiempo es de tres
segundos que si despejamos la
aceleración nos da que es igual a dos
metros por segundo al cuadrado
también podemos encontrar cuál es la
rapidez final de la ardilla usando la
primera fórmula cinemática la rapidez
final será nuestra incógnita la rapidez
inicial sigue siendo cero porque
comienza en reposo sabemos que la
aceleración es de dos y el tiempo es de
tres segundos lo que nos da una rapidez
final de seis metros por segundo y la
razón por la cual podemos usar estas
fórmulas es que sabemos que la
aceleración es constante un objeto en
caída libre o un objeto que vuela es un
objeto que se deja caer o se lanza por
el aire y que solamente tiene a la
fuerza de gravedad actuando sobre él lo
que significa que típicamente vamos a
ignorar la resistencia al aire en estos
problemas a menos que se indique lo
contrario nos interesan estos objetos ya
que su aceleración siempre es igual a
menos 9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado
en la dirección vertical para todos los
objetos que se encuentran cerca de la
tierra y ya que esta aceleración es
constante podemos usar las fórmulas
cinemáticas para describir el
comportamiento de estos objetos en caída
libre
tenemos que sustituir esto en lugar de
la aceleración vertical busquen términos
como dejar caer que significa que la
velocidad inicial es cero la velocidad
final a una altura máxima va a ser igual
a cero y la aceleración debida a la
gravedad en la dirección vertical
siempre va a ser igual a menos 9.8
metros por segundo al cuadrado pero
tengan cuidado si analizan el movimiento
de un objeto que tiene un movimiento
vertical ya que la velocidad va a
disminuir verticalmente hacia arriba
hasta que la velocidad sea cero en la
altura máxima y después la velocidad se
va a hacer cada vez más negativa
conforme vaya hacia abajo sin embargo la
aceleración va a permanecer constante en
todo el recorrido siempre va a ser de
menos 9.8 en la trayectoria hacia arriba
y la trayectoria hacia abajo incluso
cuando se detiene en la altura máxima
del movimiento la aceleración en la
dirección vertical siempre va a ser
igual a menos 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado
como luce un problema que involucra a
los objetos en caída libre digamos que
un estudiante deja caer su libro desde
una altura
h y queremos saber cuánto tiempo le
lleva al libro llegar al suelo en
términos de las cantidades dadas y las
constantes fundamentales lo que
significa que vamos a resolver este
problema simbólicamente no vamos a usar
valores aquí seguimos usando la fórmula
cinemática pero pondremos valores
simbólicos en lugar de valores reales
aquí así que del taller no va a hacer h
sino que va a ser menos h ya que dejó
caer el libro hacia abajo el cual es un
desplazamiento negativo dejó caer al
libro lo que significa que la velocidad
inicial es cero la aceleración debida a
la gravedad es de menos 9.8 pero como
nos piden resolver esto simbólicamente
no vamos a usar este valor sino que
vamos a representarlo como menos g
minúscula lage minúscula representa la
magnitud de la aceleración de la
gravedad en la dirección vertical lo que
significa que la geminus q la es
9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado
positivos ya que la aceleración debida a
la gravedad es menos 9.8 la podemos
representar como menos g minúscula ahora
despejamos el tiempo y nos queda la raíz
cuadrada de 2 h / g que es nuestra
respuesta simbólica en términos de las
cantidades dadas y las constantes
fundamentales